and uh jordan peterson went into rogue
and looking like huckleberry finn well
his pants were like looked like he was
in a river well he's in a he's you know
he was in a um he was in a uh like a uh
uh what was he in like a tux with a bow
tie
and short pants he's like you know it's
not immediately clear to me
why climate
is climate it's not immediately clear to
me
he you know he's been through it yeah
he's been through the ringer he's been
through the ringer and he's a brilliant
guy he's a smart guy yeah
and
but he looks right now like he's
uh like he's in his almost his final
form
which is a batman villain like he seems
to be he looks like he just took a break
from a catering hall handing out [ __ ]
shellfish yeah he seems like a like an
angry maitre d at a long island italian
restaurant
screaming about climate change
oh you don't like your table
i told you it's the only table here we
don't have an innumerable amount of
space that's the problem with people
they think there's an innumerable amount
of opportunities to eat you can eat the
eggplant rollatini and you can eat it
anywhere it's not immediately clear to
me if we put you in another table that
you'd be having a better thing the thing
about marxism
and the pareto principle is that
eggplant roll a teeny in any society
concentrates in the hands of fewer and
fewer people well that's correct but
it's actually so correct that you have
no idea how correct it is so it's an
underestimation of the problem your
table on the corner is an
underestimation of the problem
yeah
you just walk away and you go like
rogan needs a new car like rogenstein
has these guys but we got we need
someone new we need who's a new
professor we need like a new
like a new professor yeah because he's
you know he's great but he's he's you
know he's done it right
so we need like a new
yeah who would it be i don't know like
what other professor from some college
you never heard about
yeah it's got to be it's got to be from
a small small college that didn't matter
to anyone and they have to be the next
guy yes you know yes
well i'm sure there's a lot the money's
better yeah the money's better online
than it is that you know uh
it's gotta be like a collet like a small
college yeah
and a video's gotta go viral of like uh
a lesbian beating him with a stick yes
like just three lesbians beating him
with a lacrosse stick yeah or just a
bunch of students burning his book yeah
burning his book and they're like
pushing his car like if you see a bunch
of
and we can organize this yeah and
perhaps it has been yeah but you put
someone in a car and then the students
are just like you see the car going back
and forth and the the professor's like
you know just a bunch of kids with
purple hair just pouring milkshakes on
them as he screams and then he needs to
emerge as like the next guy yeah
and it's got to be a good like the name
has to be perfect yes like it's got to
be like uh the university is always like
uh yeah
greenfield yeah greenfield college yeah
greenfield college in wisconsin
dr eric von schlossberg
please welcome dr eric von schlossberg
so you're an anthropologist but let's
talk about microbiology no it'll be a
guy it'll be a guy it'll be a gym team
can it be a gym teacher
it has to be a guy who's who's
who's who's like
degree is in exercise science
dr eric von schlossberg from uh the
university of winnipeg
brutally beaten by four field dykes
and is now here to talk about his theory
of you know of antimatter yeah
why galileo was a hack
dr eric von schlossberg
gym teacher
university of winnipeg let's talk black
holes yeah
yeah no they um
they've really opened up their uh their
fields of interest yeah they really are
well everybody it's the the
like i we always thought about doing a
sketches funny where it's like a guy
who's like has a mentor who's a
professor
and and he sits down with him he's like
i want to let you know thank you so much
for everything you've done for me the
professor's like i'm trying to get on
logan paul's show
what are you guys you guys like are you
so are you like working on anything and
he goes yeah i'm working on getting on
impulsive
can you get me on impulsively yeah and
you go well i thought you were kind of
like weren't you working on a theory
yeah yeah i'm working on a theory of not
being broke yeah that's exactly what it
is i got a new theory called not being
broke yes and i'm trying to get my
numbers up yeah and he said a lot of
valuable things and we like jordan we've
had jordan on the show
um
you know but it's just it's it's funny
because this is a new archetype of guy
like renegade professor yeah renegade
professor back in the day there were
professors who were like protesting
vietnam yes and it was like cute
communist piece of [ __ ] but a lot of
them were like legit
protesting
a war in vietnam